TCT I
know
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet value taming giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters run homie look
what I become I'm I'm the
one so today's guest is a a a major
league baseball player and a guy I've
been following and speaking to for a
while uh he was probably one of the most
exciting players that entered into the
major leagues but I want to properly
introduce him to you in a way to see how
you would feel about this so imagine
you're in high school and you have a 4.8
GPA okay let's just assume you got a 4.8
GPA and because of your grades you can
go to UCLA early to pitch and to go to
school you're 17 years old you go to
UCLA you do your thing you're coming out
in the draft you can go second you ask
the Mariners for 20 million they say no
you go to to the Diamond bags for 7.3
million you get pick number three you
come into the major leagues right off
the bat you're doing your thing you're
trying to figure yourself out you're
young you're a a little bit of a rebel
you're in the new era social media
content creation maybe you a bit of a Ro
so think about like a younger you know
uh you know Conor McGregor coming into
the UFC where Dana White knows how to
use him right and what does Conor do he
draws all these eyeballs making one of
the greatest fights of all time with him
and uh Mayweather and he's making 100
million I believe Mayweather made $300
million so but there's still some
challenges and and you know of course
when you're a little bit uh trollish and
you're a little bit of a rebel maybe you
know you're in the playoffs ALCS maybe
game one you're messing around with your
what do you call it the Drone and you're
trying to fix it and and you're playing
for this team called the Indians and you
cut your pinky of your pitching arm
right and it's so bad that you're
playing a game game two of the alocs you
can hide your blood on your navy blue
jersey but you can't on your white pants
and no matter how much you try to
there's literally videos of the blood
dripping to the point where the skipper
on the other side had to come in and go
to the uh ump and say hey man you know
we can't have blood look what's going on
over there so they come they take him
out and coaches upset it's like what are
you doing it's a big moment sure okay
then you know frustration throws the
pitch to the center field coach comes
out what the f are you doing I'm so
sorry gets taken out gets traded
eventually goes to a team he has a a
good season and I think he gets number
three for number six for sa young he
thought he could have won it I think
this is since I don't know where you
were at but you thought you were going
to win it you were number six then he
goes and gets the biggest contract in
the history by the way at this time he's
won the sa young I think he ends up
winning the sa young with the Dodgers he
calls it the Mickey Mouse award so I
think it was a short uh uh season that
we had with Co all the stuff that's
going on but again I want you to think
about this all this stuff is going on
you know he gets a contract biggest in
the history of Major League Baseball at
the town it's a three-year contract for
$102 million okay 3 years $102 million
you get a contract like that in 2020
he's he's 20 He's 33 years old right now
which means 2020 he's late 20s 29 years
old you're on top of the world you just
got a 9 figure check okay and of course
you're having some fun and by the way
I'll put a little bit of Elon Musk in
him as well because one time he said for
69 days straight he wants to give money
to a charity of the fans choosing and
you know how much money G give gives to
the charity on a daily basis $420 69 for
69 days straight and on the 69th day he
chose to give 69,420
$69 to a charity of his choosing so yes
he is a troll that's a bit of a musk
that's a bit bit of a counter but again
if you know how to use a creative Talent
like this who's a Troll And It's
upsetting and closes one eye when he's
pitching the ball and Strikes the guy
out is screaming is on the Highlight we
all follow it gets millions of views we
can't wait to see the next time they
play it's drawing an audience that the
MLB doesn't yet have it's getting
exciting right and then all of a sudden
so again at this point you're on top of
the world wherever you go to they know
who you are they're talking about you
every day on the news you're being
written about you're on the papers you
can't you can't keep track of all the
magazine Sports magazines that are
writing about oh you know you were
quoted over here oh you know you were
over here no [__] I can't track it
anymore you're at this point then all of
a sudden you get a lot of attention of
course a lot of girls are interested in
you good-looking guy tall knows how to
play Loud vocal you know has strong
opinions is a troll also on Twitter he
had plans of 1. getting to million
followers on Twitter no no time I mean
this is the kind of a guy that's
competitive right so this girl uh is is
attracted to him a girl named Lindsey
Hill she comes in um asks them there's
texts and all this stuff that we'll talk
about there's a video we'll show some of
the text and they start hanging out and
you know then a few months later she
comes out and accuses him of sexual
assault so now keep in mind you're a
major league baseball player you're
playing for the Dodgers a city like la
girls are throwing their everything at
you right then he said wait a minute
what are we talking about here the MLB
jumps to conclusion you know how many
games they suspend him for I I want you
to think about this they suspend him for
324 games ends up
being 194 games two years later Lindsay
was lying texts were shown videos were
shown calls were shown and even the
court said if we had this earlier two
years before this would have never
happened nothing would have happened
with this person you know how much money
Linds he got $300,000 you know from who
from an insurance company not from
Trevor Bower the reason why this is very
important and why I wanted to have this
conversation with Trevor is because
there's a lot of other people in sports
who have gone through this and you you
just played in Japan in Japan his spin
rate and his velocity rate was very
comparable to the best season that he
had when he was crushing it in Major
League Baseball so it's not like well he
can't pitch anymore well no no he can't
throw no he can't do this anymore and
it's at a right now where he could
probably play in the big leagues for
another seven years but one girl cost
him a few hundred million dollar and
some of his best pitching years of his
life and fans lost that so with that
being said I wanted to properly
introduce Trevor before we get into the
story Trevor it's great to have you on
the podcast yeah it's great to be here I
watch you guys all the time so happy to
be on set and watching on YouTube well
we watched you for a long time and you
know Tom one day we're having
dinner and you know his family they're
big Dodger fans Tom was a you know
season ticket holder I don't know two
decades three decades you sat right next
to uh who's the big interviewer Larry
King and you know right behind the pitch
so he would he would follow and you were
the family's favorite pitcher is where
you were at and then one day he's like
yeah you know there was this pitcher
named Trevor Brown I said I think Trevor
DM me Trevor DM yeah and I'm like
Instagram oh [__] we did and and I'm
like oh we had this conversation
together and it led to a phone call and
all this stuff so I wanted to have Tom
here because Tom's got a different
perspective with baseball and he is a
guy that's uh you know when it comes on
to history what's happened with sports
he knows a lot about us I wanted him to
be here as well so how are you doing
right now how you feeling right now I'm
good good um it's been a rough couple
years of course but uh I think I've
managed to get through it well enough
and focused on the future that's that's
kind of been the Saving Grace just
trying to look towards the future and
figure out what I can do to make the
future better than than the past um so
yeah doing pretty good right now so
what's the level of optimism of you know
you getting everything sored away with
Lindsay where the market now knows what
happened there for you to be able to go
back on the mound and start pitching
again I don't know um I'm hopeful of
course I'm not the most optimistic
person in general I try to be a little
bit more uh realistic um just in
everything so I realize that there's a
lot of uh you a lot of potential issues
that a team would have in signing me
publicly like public relations wise um
pitching wise like I'm still one of the
best guys in the world I know I can go
out there and perform at a top level um
I played in Japan last year my uh set a
new all-time velocity record through
harder uh than I ever have in my life my
average velocity was second highest in
my career in any year
um yeah I had a really good year I'm
developed a new pitch my Arsenal is
better than it ever has been so I have
no doubts on the field that I'm able to
to perform and compete I'm just looking
for an opportunity
um so that's that's kind of where it's
at uh I'm hopeful um but not sure we'll
see how it plays out we saw the videos
when you were in Japan you were welcome
they loved you it was it seemed like it
was like a solid reception what was your
experience playing in Japan man Japan
was awesome um I could I could talk this
entire podcast about about Japan um the
bay Stars organization so the team I
played for there was the uh Yokohama Bay
stars and they were uh extremely
welcoming um I've actually known a
couple people in their front office for
a couple years now through you know
going to Japan and trying to um make
content and help grow baseball in Japan
and all that but um it was great they
were super welcoming the fan base was
super welcoming uh for people who
haven't seen games in Japan you can
imagine like a European soccer game um
with the the crowd chanting and there's
band playing the entire time and flags
and all sorts of stuff sold out every
single game so uh for the people in the
in the states if you haven't been to a
game over there it's well worth it if
you get the chance
um you know they they care a lot about
baseball as a culture um everyone loves
it it's like the number one sport there
which is really cool to be a part of um
Talent is very good I think the talent
is uh better than most people give it
credit for it kind of gets the
reputation of being like a less than MLB
league and that was not my experience at
all U I think that's not you know that's
when you look at the WBC and the results
of the five wbc's Japan's won uh three
of them so um level of competition is
very high um different of course a lot
of cultural differences and how the
game's played and what's important how
the coaches interact with players um
there's only 12 teams there's 30 in in
the MLB so there's a lot less data Al so
it's not really controlled by a central
uh operating body each team is kind of
in individual I saw a really interesting
graph one time actually um kind of like
uh revenues in 1970 um npb in Japan
actually generated more Revenue than MLB
and since then MLB is like skyrocketed
and npb has stayed flat and the reason
for that is the 12 teams there are
competing uh and here MLB is like a
collective you know MLB owns all the all
the rights to the TV they can sell it as
a as a package so the national TV deals
are there um they can drive ticket
prices they you know it's one Central
thing where in Japan it's 12 teams
competing for the fans attention so
there's no National TV deals they all
have their local TV deals it's all based
revenue is all based on um in-person
attendance so they actually they
actually have to make the Fan Experience
really good so ticket prices are down
entertainment's up like the bay Stars
would launch fireworks after every
single game so it became a thing to like
stay after the game and enjoy it they'd
have like pop stars come in and do
concerts after a baseball game to try to
drive fan engagement um so it was it was
really fun uh the people in Japan like
outside of baseball just the the people
on the streets are so polite um at least
you know my experience um so polite and
welcoming I had people coming up to me
you know I'd walk to the train station
like 20- minute walk i' you know if I
was if 10 people if less than 10 people
came up and like shook my hand and
wanted a picture or wanted to say hi or
something it was a it was a slow day so
but they did in a very respect way you
were top select is what you were you got
a taste of that on what what it was like
there yeah it was cool the the whole
experience was awesome fantastic well
you know when when um when I was
following the story closely we've
reacted to it many times with you know
what was going on with it with Lindy
Hill and we've seen her in interviews I
think she did a couple interviews where
she was called out and she like ah [__]
if you feel that way if you only knew me
if you gave me a chance to get to know
me you're like no we got to know you and
we learned a lot about you um what
what's what's what what was revealed you
know from the Lindsey hill case that
originally the way MLB
immediately jumped on it's like no you
can't do this this is not fair you know
324 million 324 games and then boom now
it's 193 whatever the number number was
to where it's at today what did MLB
learn to realize this guy's innocent you
didn't do any of it and then did they
reach out apologize has there been any
conversations there about them wanting
to speak with you about potentially what
your career is going to look like in the
future maybe we need you to go through
XYZ therapy and meet with this has that
conversation taken place uh that
conversation hasn't taken place I have
spoken to the commissioner and Deputy
Commissioner um face to face face to
face yeah I had a 20-minute conversation
with Rob and I basically I wanted to
just apologize for the things that I've
said about him in the past um and just
clear the air um didn't get the sense
that there was any you know malice or
anything like that it was a pleasant
conversation mostly I mean we talked a
little bit about the state of baseball
and growing it and stuff like that so
trying to like I want to be a positive
for the game you know I want to grow it
baseball's given me a lot um despite the
last couple years it's like I'm still in
a fantastic position in life and um you
know time with my family and uh
confidence as a person and there's
outside of the money and the fame and
all that stuff um there's other like key
lessons that I've learned through
baseball that I want the Next Generation
to be able to
experience um and so I think a lot of my
efforts to be positive for the game um
have been different than what the game
has traditionally been and I think it's
caused a lot of um like a lot of riffs
but it all comes from a place of like
trying to connect with the younger fan
base and get people interested in
baseball and um so yeah I'd love to I'd
love to work with the league we talked
about that a little bit um I apologize
for the things that I've said and the
way that I've gone about things um which
you know looking back now I'm 33 now
looking back at some of the things I did
when I was 20 and coming up in the
league I'm just very embarrassed about
them but I think that's a natural thing
like you grow hopefully you learn from
your mistakes and you do better year
after year um you know even back to my
time when I was with the Diamondbacks
when I first signed like I look back at
some of the things I did now I'm like
wow I was so immature back then but back
then I'm a 20-year-old just got drafted
in the first round I think I have
everything figured out and um you know I
ruined a lot of relationships or at
least got off to a bad start in a lot of
relationships there that uh I would like
to repair so that's kind of the the tone
of the conversation that's what I'm
trying to do I want to be a positive
really um so and and in in baseball is
it kind of like uh does Manfred is like
the president of the United States you
got 50 Governors the governor's got to
decide what they get to do and it's left
to the states to make the decision is it
a similar way where hey I'm the
commissioner you know if these guys want
to hire you it's on them but I I don't
have a prom if they hire you is that the
kind of approach okay so the way it
works is the owners actually elect the
commissioner so the commissioner works
for the owners uh for the collective
group um he's in charge of overseeing
the game and making at the end of the
day making their investment in a
baseball team profitable and making it a
good investment growing the league
growing revenues stuff like that so did
he say hey if the guys want to sign you
great uh but he didn't give an
endorsement either he didn't give a nod
to say hey guys yeah he's he's good if
you guys want to work with him was was
there an element of an endorsement where
it's it's not it's not his you know if a
team wants to sign a player they go sign
they go sign the player it's not really
his his area have you had any kind of a
uh have you pitched for anybody have you
gone have they taken a look at you Has
any team no no one's looked at you yet
no I don't think the performance is the
is the factor I mean I I pitched in
Japan last year we just saw um Yamamoto
signed with the Dodgers uh they Scout
him in Japan They Know Each team knows
kind of like how they view Japanese or
like performance in Japanese League how
it'll translate they look at the stuff
metrics the velocity spin rates the
strikeout numbers the pitch movements
all that and they make the decision and
I don't think anyone out there has any
question that I'm still one of the most
elite guys out there um it's it's a
little different than you know other
free agencies because the talent is not
the question and the money is not the
question like I'm willing to play for
the league minimum with incentives I
just want an opportunity to go out there
and Pitch to prove that I'm still one of
the best guys I realize that there's
risk in signing me for the other side I
want it to be a good deal I don't want
one side to get screwed and so I want to
pitch for the league minimum with
incentives so if I pitch like the best
guy in the world then I can earn money
like that and if I don't then there's no
risk for the team uh so it's really not
a question of talent or money it's a
question of Optics I think and that's
the that's the battle we're fighting
what do you think the risk is if you're
major like if we were you're you're in a
negotiation situation right you have to
always put yourself in the other
person's shoes to say okay this is what
they want this is what they fear what do
you think is their concern and what can
you as a player do or agree to in the
contract to get them to not worry about
that one or two or three things yeah so
so I think the first part identifying
the risks a little bit easier than the
solutions um identifying risks you have
Optics um publicly so fan based stuff oh
you know I'm perceived to be a certain
way you sign me it's like oh well you
don't care about women or you don't you
know value you know how do I explain
this to my kids like there's those types
of questions in the with the fan base
there's internal stuff I'm sure there's
you know each these organizations are
massive so you have a lot of different
people that feel a lot of different ways
so you have risk of internal culture
disruption with the front office um and
the support staff I don't think anyone
really questions the clubhouse stuff I
you know I'm fine in the clubhouse I
have a good reputation behind closed
doors in the clubhouse publicly it's a
little bit different but um so there's
those risks and then there's sponsors
you know um do people
drop uh sponsorships there's a a
financial component to it as well um I
think the upside is there you know you
spend league minimum that you have to
spend anyway and you potentially get
someone that pitches at a $40 million a
year level um but those are some of the
those are some of the concerns that I've
identified how I go about solving those
you know I I personally don't think that
it's a more than a three or four day
story when it when if someone signs me I
think it goes away I think I handle it
and then it's just about baseball I
could be very wrong on that that's just
my personal opinion um so I don't know
how to solve that one I I've I'm happy
have any conversations and work with the
team in any way whether it's uh having
conversations with the local media the
national media if that's something that
they want me you know being involved in
the community I like being involved in
the community that's something I'm very
passionate about anyway connecting with
youth um all those different things I'm
happy to have those conversations
ultimately like I said earlier I want it
to be a partnership and I want to do
well for the team that signs me and I
want them to do well for me and so both
parties are happy um so I'm willing to
address any concern that they have I
just don't know how to do that ahead of
time you know if I go do a bunch of
media and address stuff then it's like
all right well now you're in the media
you know a lot with this as you know
kind of surrounding this topic maybe a
team just wants me to not be in the
media and play baseball I'm fine with
that maybe a team wants me to address it
but different teams feel different ways
so it's hard to have one
solution that like satisfies a whole uh
the whole of uh the 30 teams um
ultimately I just looking for a you know
to sit down with someone and like have a
conversation and like prove be given the
chance to prove that I can be a positive
and that I can grow the fan base I can
connect with the local community I can
pitch well on the field I can help the
players in the clubhouse become better
pitchers uh help the team win you know
bring playoffs and World Series to the
to the city I think there's a lot of
positives I know I can deliver on those
things I just need to be given the
opportunity
so do do you think um with any of these
teams like is there any teams you
wouldn't play for or you'd play for
anybody they give you an opportunity
today no I'd play for anyone I don't
have like you mentioned earlier that I'm
kind of a troll like I've trolled a lot
and it's all it's all trying to drive
fan engagement um I have no I have no
problems with any of the teams um I'd
play for the Dodgers again I'd play for
the Astros I'd play it doesn't it
doesn't matter to me like you just want
to get back into and play I want to play
I spent 30 years of my life developing a
skill set that's like top 15 in the
world and I'd like to be able to use it
because I love playing I love competing
and I feel like I have a lot left to
give yeah and you your your preparation
the way you would go about preparing it
was very different and weird and
controversial and nobody understood it
and even in what which team was it you
were playing for that even the pitchers
were coming to you to learn from the
data on how to improve their games like
you were helping other pitchers around
you on how to become a better picture so
but but let me do this for some of the
audience that doesn't know the whole
story okay they don't know what really
happened uh with Lindsey Hill you made a
video okay and the video was the whole
story with what took place and the texts
were out and you kind of negotiated
where you could talk about it for the
rest of your career CU that was
obviously very important you even sued
her you came back and Su her can you
walk the audience through maybe the
process of what happened events here's
what happened first one day I'm doing
this we met here here's what took place
then this happened whatever information
can give on a process for the audience
that doesn't know and then we can go
into some of the other topics yeah uh
high level uh um she reached out to me
on Instagram we started talking on
Instagram um eventually you know she
came over to my house uh one night so
she lived in San Diego I was in Pasadena
she drove up to Pasadena had a nice
night together decided to meet up uh 3
weeks later about she came back had a
great night she left no problems and
then a couple days later I'm getting
texts about I'm in the hospital and you
know what's going on and she started
accusing me of things that did not
happen eventually she um filed a a
domestic violence restraining order
um basically saying she was you know
scared or in danger uh that's a public
filing so her written version of events
went public the media picked up on it I
was put on administrative leave by MLB
not allowed to pitch um there was I I
didn't have any chance at that point to
defend myself um we went to Family Court
I think 6 weeks or so later we had four
days there where a judge heard her side
of the story I didn't I didn't testify
um there's an open investigation so my
lawyers advised me not to say anything
and so the the judge heard her side of
why she needed a protective order and
then denied it which for those who don't
know that's like the lowest standard uh
in all the like the entire Justice
System the lowest standard of proof and
the judge judge threw it out and said
that she had misled the court materially
misled the court um and there was no
wrongdoing on on my on my part uh then
the um I think that was in August I
could have the month wrong it's long
time ago now but um there's an open
investigation obviously the allegations
against me were very serious and as they
were they should be investigated to the
fullest extent so as the pass police
department and um I think other I don't
exactly what all other entities were
involved but um as they investigated I
was still on administrative leave so I
wasn't able to play for the remainder of
the 2021 season that lasted into spring
training time um where I was on
administrative leave in
2022 they uh eventually um decided not
to press any charges so I was never
arrested never charged with
anything um and then I was after that
suspended by MLB for originally two
years so by the time we went through the
process of
appeal
um uh in December I believe of 202 uh
2022 um the suspension was reduced to
194 games which is the number of games
that ID missed and then I was cleared to
play immediately I still had a one year
left on my Dodger contract so in January
of 2023 they uh released me um from that
and then I went and played in Japan in
2023 um and now we're here so that's
like High level uh sequence of events
Now text came out about her Rob can you
prepare that video maybe the first 90
seconds will be good for the audience to
see I think this is you actually showing
the text just played from the beginning
go for it next victim star piter for the
Dodgers a text lindsy Hill sent to a
friend before she ever even met me what
should I steal she asked another in
reference to visiting my house for the
first time the answer take his money so
how might that work I'm going to his
house Wednesday she said I already have
my hooks in you know how I roll then
after the first time we met net worth is
51 mil she said [__] you better secure
the bag was the response but but how was
she going to do that need daddy to choke
me out she said being an absolute [__]
to try to get in on his 51 million read
another text then after the second time
we met former Padre's pitcher Jacob
Nicks told her you got to get this bag
I'll give you 50,000 Lindsay replied her
AA sponsor asked her at one point do you
feel a tiny bit guilty not really she
replied since then her legal team has
approached me multiple times about
coming to a financial settlement but as
I done since day one I refused to pay
her even a single scent uh in August of
21 lindsy Hill's claims were heard in
court and during those legal proceedings
critical information was deliberately
and unlawfully concealed from me and my
legal team uh information like this
video which was taken by Lindsay Hill
herself the morning after she claimed
she was brutally attacked emotionally
traumatized and desperate to get away
from me and now we have the metadata so
there can be no dispute uh it was taken
mere minutes before she left my house on
the morning of May 16th 2021 without my
knowledge or consent of course uh in it
you can see her lying in bed next to me
while I'm sleeping smirking at the
camera without a care in the world or
any marks on her face
I think it paints a pretty clear picture
of what actually happened the evening of
May 15th and why the video was
originally concealed from
us yeah uh after hearing the evidence
available to her judge Diana gold
saltman found that Lindsey Hill had
misled the court she found her claims to
be materially misleading uh she denied
her request for domestic violence
restraining order and she found that no
sexual assault or non-consensual conduct
took place now some of you might not
know about restraining order hearings I
know I didn't but uh I've since learned
that uh it's extremely rare for a
request for a restraining order to be
denied because the standard of proof
that you need to obtain one is extremely
low so you can make of that what you
will the fact is I was never arrested I
was never charged with a crime and I won
the only legal proceeding that took
place without my side of the story even
being heard uh and most importantly as
I've said from day one I never sexually
assaulted Lindsey Hill or anyone else
for that matter so I sued her which
prompted her to counter sue me quite
frankly regardless of the outcome in
court I've paid significantly more in
legal fees than Lindsay Hill could ever
pay me in her entire life and I knew
that would be the case going in but the
lawsuit was never about the money for me
it was the only way for me to obtain
critical information to clear my name uh
the discovery process in that lawsuit
recently concluded at which point uh
Lindsay Hill's legal team again came to
us with another proposal to resolve the
case uh this time however they weren't
seeking any money from me having
received uh much of the information that
had been hidden from us a small portion
of which I've referenced here um I was
willing to agree to the terms proposed
both parties would drop their respective
lawsuits and neither of us would pay
either side any money um I also retained
my right to speak publicly about the
case something I have not been at
Liberty to do since June of 2021 so as
of today both lawsuits have been settled
now over the last 2 years I've been
forced to defend my Integrity uh and my
reputation in a very public setting but
hopefully this is the last time I have
to do so as I prefer to just remain
focused on doing my job uh winning
baseball games and entertaining fans
around the world so today I'm happy to
be moving on with my
life how much did it cost you if you
were to put a number to it last however
long it's been renewal in contracts
additional things you could do maybe a
World Series win maybe two would during
that time you were you know on a team
that had a lot of legs to do a lot of
things what do you think it cost you uh
talking future earnings potential as
well give me all of it yeah during that
time and future earnings
um it's during that time it's mid let's
see mid eight figures um between legal
cost
suspension um you know contract uh off
field stuff endorsements all that uh
lifetime earnings probably 350 is
conservative um I was making 42.5
million a year at that point I was 30 so
if I decline uh linearly from 30 to 40
and end up at 40 making 20 million which
would be well below you know what guys
like uh Sherer and Verlander are making
at 40 um let's just say I declined
linearly then I would have averaged 31
or 30,
750 uh for 10 years so that' be 300
million plus
the you know and you were innocent so
$350 million to $400 million and you
were innocent yeah okay so you know the
the one thing I I think about myself is
I have two ways I process this but I you
know I want to kind of see where you
take this on one end you know Dana White
knew how to use Conor okay Conor came in
you used to do your arms like this when
you would go and then who's the guy you
pitch with your I Stu come out and and
he hadit a home run and he did this to
you and he by the way that's freaking
awesome right that makes me want to
watch sports center at night that's the
whole point so I learning from Connor
like yeah in order to sell a UFC fight
you have to have a reason for people to
want to watch so you have to have a
storyline going into that match that's
right so there's no story lines in
baseball anymore it used to be you know
you have Yankees Red Sox was this big
rivalry then free agency came around and
players move around so much that the
players don't pride is gone right so
there's no story lines in baseball
during the regular season so you need
story lines you need people to like
antagonize you need people to fight back
so tatis I you know did something in
spring training where I pitched with one
eye closed struck out one of the Padre's
hitters it was fun made for good social
Clips a lot of Engagement and then he
ended up hitting a home run off me and
like celebrated with his Dugout by
putting one hand over his eye that's
great it went viral it was everywhere
baseball was talked about on live like
on national TV for three days because of
it like I don't care that I'm on the
like quote unquote losing end of that
it's good for baseball I'm going to be
on the winning end sometimes and losing
end but you need storylines you need you
need social media clips that connect
with youth like when Steph Curry hits a
three in an All-Star game like it's
meaningless game but it's trending on
Twitter and x and everywhere it's
everywhere Mike Trout one of the best
baseball players not the best baseball
player of all time makes an insane catch
Robs a home run like you can't find it
on social media like you got to connect
with the youth where the youth are and
was the whole point of all that and so
you know I I don't need to go out of my
way to like antagonize people or
whatever it's an entertainment sport
like I'm trying to entertain people it's
funny I wrote that one word here I said
that one thing because when you u i put
a tweet out the other day about the fact
that NFL is destroying uh what do you
call it NBA and George Carl responded
and he was upset at what I said about
the NBA because I feel LeBron's
destroyed the game my opinion again and
specifically with the eyeballs where the
most viewed playoff game of all time I
think was game six of Utah Jazz against
the you know Chicago Bulls got 38
million views or 36 million views and
ever since then we we've hit 30 I think
once or twice everything's in the 13s
and the 12s and the 14 and the 18 number
it's dropped right and MLB as somebody
who loves baseball I'm a I'm a DieHard
baseball I grew up just following stats
of B baseball because baseball offered
me more stats than any other Sport and I
like numbers I'm a numbers guy right but
if if I was the MLB
okay which I'm not but if I'm a CMO or
president or Commissioner of MLB here's
what I'd be thinking about you know what
case study I'd be paying attention to
today one case study if found the MLB
how much eyeballs and Market has Taylor
Swift brought to the NFL think about
that how much you know if I'm a betting
man the record do you know what the
record is for the most people watching
the Super Bowl I think it's 114.4
million can you can you type in most
viewed Super Bowl of all time I want to
say it's 114.4 million us audience us
audience and I think it's 2015 or 2014
what year is it 2015 there you go I got
it right so 114.4 million 2015 Super
Bowl right is the most viewed Super Bowl
of all time I'm willing to bet this
Super Bowl could get close to 130 that's
how crazy the Super Bowl I think is
going to get right depending on how they
measure it and what it's going to be
like of course A lot of people are going
to go to party so you're not going to be
using multiple devices but I think it's
going to get to the 120 to 130 Mark and
I think it's going to break the record
why because the NFL got a chance to get
into a market they were not in before
right they brought eyeballs they
couldn't bring in before so with
baseball you know what's baseball going
to do to get eyeballs that they wouldn't
bring in before let's take a few case
studies of what players changed a sport
right Tiger Woods what audience did he
bring nonwhites it wasn't just blacks
it's nonwhites if you were were not
white you were following tiger you got
to be you telling me a black kid is
going around beating every yes freaking
Underdog I'm all in with this guy let's
see what he's going to do and B wow sick
insane so golf goes to hold everybody's
wearing tiger shirts tiger shoes and a
10 year younger audience immediately
know Game Changer right okay so you go
what did Connor do to UFC changed the
game Connor did to UFC right brought all
these eyeballs and you know up yeah no
question about it as an entrepreneur of
a Fortune 500 company who brought
eyeballs to capitalism Elon Musk why
he's a troll he would have fun he was
different he would be selling his Tesla
for how much $699,000 out of all the
prices you can sell Tesla for you mean
to tell me you want to sell for $69,000
yes he would do everything with $420 and
69 and he was again toying with
everybody right so it brought eyeballs
you need agitation you need to agitate
the enemy that brings you know a level
of me being interested in well you know
the other day did you see who was the
one that got punched in the face the the
the Toronto guy uh Batista got punched
in the face by the second baseman or and
then you're like wait what once the next
time they're playing whether you like it
or not you're following this right so
Maguire did this to baseball in 98 save
the game I think you had an element of
that and you have an element of when I
say had I mean that's when we saw it
right where you were making people who
are like who is this guy who is this guy
wants to be a YouTuber he wants to be an
influencer but he's a baseball guy and
he's got this stick that he's going like
this with what the hell is wrong with
this guy he's interesting why is he
pitching it from the center field from
the left field to the right field the
coaches are upset at him you're going to
throw out your elbow that's the fastest
way to do this why does he have to have
a running star to pitch to The Cure all
of these things you did that was weird
do you think there was an element of of
you being a little too controversial for
baseball that people don't know how to
handle you yeah for sure um I
think I have a lot of thoughts on that
um one I didn't go about it in the
perfect way I you know it's one thing to
do like YouTube and be out there social
media wise and I let I antagonize people
obviously in my organizations too I was
very bullheaded on like I know what I'm
talking about and I was right on a lot
of things things I was also wrong on a
lot of things and a little bit more
humility would have done well behind the
scenes so I don't want to try to absolve
myself of all responsibility here but um
I think that baseball is a very
traditional game it's got a very old a
much older audience than a lot of other
sports and I think more than any other
sport the fan base wants baseball to
stay pure to like baseball and what they
grew up with and and all that and uh the
landscape is changing I think that you
need to have have more entertainment in
baseball you need and in order to have
entertainment you have to have those
things that are different that are
quirky they're you know you have to have
story lines uh friction like you need
those things to get talked about and so
I'm willing to do that I've never much
cared you know if people like or dislike
me um that's a whole another story about
my childhood but uh I was willing to
play that part and willing to do that um
I viewed it as good for the game um I
think a lot of people viewed it as
disruptive it caused a lot of
uh attention which is what it was
designed to do but that is viewed
sometimes as a negative like oh it's all
about you or you know you're in the
media so much everyone else in the
clubhouse is getting asked about you and
the things that you do and so it's very
centered I got the impression from a
couple teams um over the years that they
viewed it as a negative all the eyeballs
that I would bring to my social channels
and to um you know the the Vlog on
YouTube and Twitter profile and stuff
they viewed it as a negative because it
was so much media attention on one
player it wasn't on the team but that's
what sells people wear LeBron jerseys
they don't wear generic like Laker
jerseys anymore it's people are fans of
players they follow their favorite
player where they go all of that I'm
okay with the only thing I have a
problem with as an owner if I was an
owner that you were playing for my team
and you're messing around with a drone
before the ALCS I would lose my mind I
swear to God I would be like what is
wrong with this guy we're about to win a
we have a shot those are the kind of
things you know like like in the Army
you sign a contract you're in the Army
guess what we're going to go party on
the weekend all don't just don't be
stupid we're going to go do our thing
but if you harm your body that's
government property what are you doing
harming the body you're hurting us right
so that was the part where you the
creativity and all of that stuff fine
antagonizing fine calling out your own
team you're playing for it's just a code
you just don't do that and you try to do
it in the most subtle way possible like
Michael used to do it and Michael was
very classy when he would call out his
own team he would say these guys that
put a great team together but the
players come here to watch the the fans
come here to watch the players play not
the GM and the management that was his
way of saying what he did but the injury
stuff you know that's that's uh that's
when it's affecting the team those
things are things that bother me more
that I would be concerned about than you
going out there and doing what you're
doing yeah you know what I'm saying I
think that comes with maturity anyways
there's a difference between being you
know this phase you you're a young 33
you just turned 33 last week or 10 days
January 18th I think right 17th you just
turned so it's not like you were 33 and
a half going on 34 you're a fresh 33
right yeah um so you know you still got
a run rate
but
um going going with this theme of
marketing branding all of that stuff do
you think sometimes the first person
that does it gets destroyed ousted then
they come back and say listen some of
the stuff Trevor was was kind of cool
and you know what maybe if the next guy
we got to be able to handle this next
guy in a better way let's make sure we
coach him that when a girl DMS you and
they want to come over and all this
stuff why don't you take a page out of
some of Derek Jeter's Playbook where you
know they got to sign a NDA and have
lawyers protecting it because you're
officially Target like did you have that
as well when girls were coming over your
room or no you know what I'm talking
about where hey here's a signed a
contract it's interesting CU like it's
uh today's society it's almost if you
have someone sign an NDA you're like oh
well why would you have them sign NDA if
you're not doing anything and if that
comes out then it's just like you're
almost guilty before just because you
had an NDA you got to protect yourself
though i' I've known players though that
have faced that that um it got you know
kept from the public eye but they had
you know that's part of the threat like
oh you have me sign this NDA if this
goes public you're going to be looked at
as doing something wrong you don't want
that pay me some money like that's very
common in in athletics so even just an
NDA like what's the penalty for breaking
it a lot of these girls don't have
nearly the money that it costs the you
know if that goes public the the girl
doesn't have the amount of money that
would cost the athlete right the
athletes are making so much money of
course so it's like there's no penalty
to them in you can't tell me other
players in like NBA they ran through
girls right and what happened they you
don't see like you see Michael doesn't
have a lot of stuff that came back with
that and we know Michael had a lot of
fun right you got magic are you kidding
me like magic he said himself you know
in one of the interviews he says I had I
don't know what the number was he said I
had 14 girls at the same time one time
okay and he said I ran through a
thousand probably and the the number he
gave I believe was a thousand nothing
came back so maybe that's in the 80s and
it's a different era we're talking about
where it's now when the meoo movement
became hot but today if I'm your lawyer
if I'm your manager you know we're we're
getting the uh uh uh you know the movie
that uh George Clooney did with
Katherine zit Jones you ever seen that
movie movie where they're trying to get
a prenuptial and at the end he's like I
love you so yeah that's the one what is
it called rob you got that up real
quickly in intoler what is it called int
Intolerable Cruelty oh it's done by
Brian graser I just saw him last week at
the polar Lounge so so Intolerable
Cruelty and the whole concept is about
what the Macy prenup yeah that you can't
break the ma PR up listen you're a guy
you're young what are you going to do
you're going to go not having sex for 10
years and you play baseball like is
Yankees going to say hey here signed a
contract but guess what for the next 10
years you can't get together with a girl
your temper is probably going to be
worse in the locker room we need you to
have some fun on privately as well right
but for me I would probably go one
protect myself if I'm a manager of yours
or a lawyer of yours dude I'm finding
out exactly the right way to write the
contract agreement to make sure nothing
can happen to you even to the point
of hi
my name is Trevor what's your name
Jackie Jackie how do we meet such and
such who dm' who I dm'd you can you
please show proof that you dm' me boom
and we're going to have some fun right
now yes yes you were not forced to be
here no I chose to be here can you
please great this goes in a file okay
and then your lawyer and whatever saves
that file today's era yeah if you don't
protect yourself in some creative ways
and by the way I'm not a lawyer so I'm
not saying that's what I would be doing
but to me when you're coming up was
there talks on the inside where the next
Trevor Bowers that's going to come up
look don't do this don't do this don't
do this have this lawyer do this before
you do this talk to this player that
used to be here hey Johnny can you coach
such and such to make sure he's a
good-looking guy he's going to go
through a lot of this what can he do to
protect himself against girls are going
to want to use me too against him talk
to my lawyer this does that take place
behind closed doors or no I've not had
any of those conversations I think it's
an important one to have I think the
social media landscape really blowing up
over the last 10 years has created a lot
of opportunities for things like this to
happen and it's probably moved a lot
faster than the industry is ready for
and able to kind of compensate for um I
think those discussions need to be had I
it's it's very hard to figure out a
solution though there's a lot of ways
around things like even if you have all
the text messages like I have all the
text messages even if you have video
like the morning after and there's no
marks on girl they they had the video
earlier it wouldn't have gone right they
did say that one clip if they had it
immediately it wouldn't have gone this
far so that would have helped yeah so I
think the you know keeping all the all
the documentation is very important and
you know if you can find some way to I
don't know get consent to video the
thing or audio or some some record of
what actually happened would be
important that's you know it's
double-edged short on that front but I
agree with you you have to have
something that's going to protect you
um unfortunate part is like the actual
implementation of it and how you do that
and then the athletes willingness to
actually do it every single time like
it's it's a lot like there there's
solutions that need to be discovered
there but when I joined the army to
first thing my uh uh MEAP station then
you go to your unit they said hey 15
will get you 20 that was the biggest
line in the Army 15 will get you 20 what
is 15 will get you 20 you're 19 years
old you hook up with someone's
15-year-old daughter you're going to get
20 years years what you're saying sge
you ID everybody you want me to ID a
girl yep even if they look 24 you ID
them so whenever we would go where was
point of something happening you'd have
to say can I see your ID yeah you're
stupid no can I see your ID are you
serious yes you want me to you want yeah
23 years old okay cool let's go yeah
versus it was oh can't right so even the
even military would prep soldiers to set
them up for Success not set them up for
failure I don't know if or in
orientation they talk to about this kind
of stuff I would assume they do yeah
I've never had a conversation like that
you mean to tell me nobody in major
leagues any of the teams you were part
of talk to about how to handle girls
that come up to you and DM you I've
never had and they may talk to other
players I've never had it you know that
that's consistent with things that I've
read and heard that there are more
counselors that are in college football
right now that talk about Cleat Chasers
frat parties and things like this to be
careful with in the age of social media
than there are in Major League Baseball
I've heard that the NBA which dates back
to Sean Kemp um actually has some level
of counseling that they do especially
Financial counseling because there's a
guy named truck who took a lot of money
from a lot of NBA players excuse me and
NFL players so there's like this
financial and other things that are
coming in certain sports but I've heard
that Major League Baseball hey you're
number seven you report to the Oklahoma
City little ducks in four months
congratulations come and if you're a
first rounder come to the podium put on
the hat and that we won't see you for 3
years until you come up there's there's
a lot of conversations that happen
around how to handle media in interviews
like we'll go through media training and
okay when they ask this question how do
you deflect here watch some interviews
of football players basketball players
here's some things that they did well
here some things that they did wrong
here's how to say words without saying
anything at all and like just pass the
interview and not make any controver
like we have a lot of those types of
conversations but and we have you know
Major League Baseball has like the
domestic violence uh trainings that
every player goes through every
Every Spring training and you know if a
girl is too drunk and you know can't
consent then that would be sexual
assault like training of that type of
thing but there's never been a
discussion at least that I've had on
like okay you could face this type of
situation here's something that you can
do as a single guy with millions of
dollars like ahead of meeting up with a
girl like here's best practices on blah
blah blah blah blah it's kind of been a
hands-off like your personal life your
is your personal life um I mean but that
I don't know where I stand on that
because like your personal life should
be like your your thing you should have
some sort of training but it also that I
feel like there should be a separation
between your your job you come to work
and then like what you are doing on the
side of course there's a separation but
I have to prepare you for Success not
for failure so if I'm running a team you
know we're we're having that
conversation very very early and and you
know I'm having it if I'm the skipper
I'm having it if I'm the the captain I'm
having it if I'm the senior guy on the
team I'm having it if I'm the GM I'm
having it as the older brother coming in
yeah there's got to be like Antoine
Walker one time in Chicago we're having
a cigar with
him and Antoine Walker career earnings
can you type of what Antoine Walker's
career earnings are just happen Antoine
Walker career earnings I think he made4
$13 million $114 million $18 million
okay so he made good amount of money got
nothing what happened he said one time I
was hanging out with Michael and
Michael's playing $100,000 hands or
whatever the number was said I thought I
could play $100 million $100,000 hands
[__] I realized I can't play 100,000
Auto hands I'm not at Michael's level of
money right so what happened to him he
lost everything who signed him Morgan
Stanley Dean wter signed him what did
they do with Antoine Walker with Morgan
I think Morgan Stanley signed him can
you Ty in antoan Walker Morgan Stanley
Dean witer Morgan Stanley signed him and
him and Morgan Stanley worked together
to talk to players that were coming to
to the league on how to manage their
finances okay and and what to do with
mistakes to make and don't do this and
don't do that and be careful yeah right
there Morgan Stanley Global Sports
entertainment teams up with former
professional athletes Antoine Walker
being one of them Bart Scott brings real
life lessons of athletes so then
athletes are like say so managers are
going to come and do this the other day
Matt R the comedian you know Matt R the
guys that's going viral he says he got a
phone call from Dave Chappelle he says I
was about to
he saved me
$750,000 because I had a lawyer that I
was paying 5% on every deal I was doing
and Chappelle told me no talk to this
guy he'll do it for $5,000 it's not a
big deal he said Chappelle Sav me 5
$750,000 just by telling me right there
just by telling me uh how long's this
clip
Rob 49 seconds yeah can you just
play Dave Chappelle what's the best
piece of advice he's giving you he saved
me 3 qu of a million dollars on a lawyer
they wanted us to go with this 5% lawyer
which would have been 34 of million for
a certain deal and he was like no I've
got a guy who do it hourly cost me a
couple Grand he saved
$7,000 so so you know Chappelle's
playing a role of a mentor yep I think
baseball's got to also be talking to
each other and kind of and maybe they
are and I'm not speculating I don't know
you're telling me they don't do it but I
think that would be the one thing I
would do as an owner because it's a new
Target DM is a new Target you're a new
Target after you um but I still want to
be able to use your antics yeah you know
what I'm saying as long as we create a
certain set of criteria to say I don't
care if you create content here's a
couple things don't leak secret stuff
that we're doing internally because if
the skipper that can't trust you then
he's not going to share everything that
they're doing strategically CU you're
talking too much don't disrespect
management and the team and don't hurt
yourself yeah as long as you know you
follow those three basic criterias okay
go dude create controversy talk about
about others and do that kind of stuff
and maybe even you know I don't know if
baseball uh um I think baseball's filled
with a lot of conservatives and
politically that maybe vote for Trump
but I don't know if many of them are
vocal about it no okay so there's a
there's a baseball probably has more
conservatives than any other of the NFL
and NBA it has more but they're low-key
about it they're quiet about it some of
them are the biggest Superstars Face of
the league but no one knows about it
they keep it to themselves maybe that's
because they don't want to Le the lose
the opposition of audience or something
like that okay totally I don't have a
problem with that but I understand why
they would say that but those would be
my criterias when I'm paying somebody a
hundred some million dollars over a
threeyear period 40 million year I got
to protect my investment yeah no doubt
you know what's interesting there's I
don't want use the word hypocrisy but
baseball's been very very slow and they
always give themselves the excuse oh
it's colorful characters right you've
probably heard it described as that it's
like a code word in baseball I don't
know if the players of your generation
remember anything about Bill VEC the
owner of the white sock like read any of
the History Bill VEC had disco
demolition light where everyone brought
an album that was disco music to a
double header and at at at the break
between the double header uh you were to
they were going to take all these albums
and blow them up in center field until
the fans got a little ripped because
it's a double header and apparently it
was warm and beer is flowing and
Budweiser in baseball will go back many
generations and disco demolition night
be became a disaster as the albums were
thrown on the field and the second half
of the double header was cancelled that
was not a player promotional event 98
cents to attend the game yeah with a
disco record discounted admission for
teenagers this is July 12th 1979
discount mission for teenagers they were
trying to get the kids to come in with
their mom and dad and so we called Bill
VEC you know and have you ever seen the
pictures of the Chicago White Socks that
were in softball shorts like the old
yeah they were light BL
guess what that was an owner and we were
we refer and what he was what was he
trying to do he was trying to bring
younger people to the ballpark disco
there they are there's Mark is that the
bird Mark fidr looks like him yeah
probably uh by the way somebody who was
experimenting as you were with finger
position and things like that and trying
to do it so baseball needs to look back
and see that in its Heritage there have
been people that have tried to bring
more people to the ballpark try to bring
a little controversy now disco Dem
listen light wasn't supposed to end with
a forfeiture and a cancellation of the
second game which made the bullpen happy
because Yep they're all coming out oh
man I got to throw again yeah are we
serious here and um Bill VEC and he
tried to bring so much to it and so
baseball's had its colorful characters
but they sent tents to handwave Pat and
just let them go away as colorful
characters but they were trying to bring
more to the game bring an excitement to
the game and I give credit to Reggie
Jackson there was a a film I saw Reggie
Jackson turns this guy after a game can
you not interrupt me here I'm doing an
interview and you need to not interrupt
me can you just go do that over there
and it was still rolling and he was here
with the camera and he said listen I got
to talk this up I'm talking to good
Christian families with their other kids
come in here I'm speaking love over here
leave me be so he understood what he was
trying to do there not and there was
nothing salacious in that particular
moment Reggie Jackson but he knew that
what was hisob he was Mr October he was
a candy bar his job was bring more by
the way he was a controversial like a
little bit of a he inol himself Billy
Martin got into each other's I love it
though that's baseball that's what you
you want to go to the next game to see
what's going on but we call it a
colorful character and we get back to
calming down and now we worry about
let's make the base bigger so we can
have a tenth of a second more steals
let's put a pitch clock so that we can
get into an entertainment length um it's
what they're looking at as movies we got
to stay under two and a half hours this
has got to be look at NBA game 2 hours
15 minutes we got to get this into movie
length we got to get this so they're
worried about those things that's why
the pitch clock is here that's why only
too many uh Mound visits that's why the
bases are bigger and we've done these
things to do that so and I feel like
baseball's attacking some of the issues
but they're not like releasing people to
be people and to be personalities
because it brings people in not in such
a way that would offend somebody or
somebody saying something awful but I
think baseball needs to know that in its
Heritage there were people that were
trying to do it and they just let them
go away and get back to calm old
baseball yeah I think the MLB's done a
decent job of trying some new
initiatives um trying to shorten the
game to appeal to more people they've
tried to bring in some social
influencers in different markets you
mentioned earlier building a bridge to a
different market with the Super Bowl and
Taylor Swift baseball's trying to do
that with some of their uh some of their
like content I forget what it's called
the MLB Creator program or something I
probably getting the name wrong um but
they're trying some things and that's
that's a positive I think the the
biggest thing you can do is create story
lines like you have to have story lines
people will care about people will tune
in to watch a story they'll tune in to
watch two guys fight that they really
trust and believe hate each other it
doesn't matter if they actually hate
each other or not but if the audience
thinks that they do they'll tune in to
watch people will watch a three-hour
baseball game if they think Red Sox
Yankees there might be a brawl I really
want to see this matchup of the starting
pitcher and you know I want to see
Clemens face Piaza and the after the
World Series and the bat issue and I
want to see those things I want to see
you know rug odor and Bautista when is
the next time those two teams are going
to play what's going to happen people
will tune in and watch the entire game
if there's enough of a storyline there
so that's that's what I'm was trying to
you last time I was playing that's what
I was trying to to do is create some
micro story lines like leading into my
start I only pitch every fifth or sixth
day so I can't do it every single game
but like leading into my start what's
the story line going into it is there a
rivalry with another team is it a
rivalry with their player is it
something that I'm going to you know can
I do this thing during a game like those
types of things need to happen more and
I think that um that's one thing that's
like really missing is how do you train
players to develop those story lines
while at the same time avoiding the
controversial stuff that's going to be
seen as like a negative for the league
do they want athletes creating content
or no is it a environment where it's
like hey we do want like you know
draymond's right now doing a podcast or
you know you got a couple players that
in the NBA are doing a podcast even
Parsons right from uh uh what do you
call it cowboys what's his name the
Michael Michael Parson he's freaking
awesome by the way what a great
communicator the guy is and a sack
machine he's a great player and a
communicator and personality but I think
he is even a better like I don't know if
I can say that cuz he's that good of a
player but he's a ridiculous personality
right so what is it doing oh so you said
this and here's what we're going to do
you think I'm going to do this you want
to say something wait till you see what
happens when we face each other I can't
wait for the game yeah I can't wait for
the game I'm like hell yeah let's see
what's going to happen with the game r i
want to F I want to see that matchup so
I think there's an element that you know
and and by the way it's a little risky
because Draymond could say anything
right cuz he's a little risky as well
like Draymond is a good example to use
the other day he hit Anthony Davis in
the face and he's like no I didn't he
hit him in the face it was a you know
with he him not intentionally he was
trying to get the ball but it still hit
Davis in the face and but there's
eyeball still that's coming with that
like for me if I watch highlights of
baseball you kind of mention a few of
them or basketball I like to watch a
little bit of you
know Wallace Ron Ares okay back in the
days if you know which one I'm talking
about the Detroit you know I want to
watch you know Charles Barkley picking
up Shaq I want to watch Larry Bird get
being held back like this by Moses
Malone while Julius Irving is going like
this I want to watch you know Shaq
against the who was the Detroit Pistons
player that he hit in the face his
rookie season I want to see crazy stuff
like that you're not like right now the
NBA doesn't play defense everybody's
averaging 140 points a game no one gives
a [__] about that kind of a game there
is no feistiness everybody's friends I
don't care to watch it there is no body
that's facing somebody that they have
any kind of a you know we want to those
guys even last week with Stephen A he
says the the sport is missing the
antagonism the agitation that's what
made it exciting it doesn't have any of
that right now matter of fact they've
made it softer and softer and softer and
softer the smallest thing you look away
they give you a technical foul it's the
softest league right now with referees
we got in
the uh uh in the NBA and uh
NFL is having some record-breaking
numbers right now some of it could be
Taylor with some of it is the fact that
competition is just really really good
and Mahomes is an exciting guy to watch
and doing what he's doing but to me with
the MLB I
wonder if they were to bring a social
media strategist you know somebody from
the industry that knows what like the
CMO from I don't know Snapchat Tik Tok
Facebook YouTube t whoever whichever one
of these guys that knows what they're
doing bring them in and then say and
then bring a Gardner in or a consulting
firm you know somebody that knows the
data and YouTube and content then bring
a McKenzie in bring a BCG in right and
say hey what do you think about and you
don't even tell the players about it
what do you think about us doing this is
this a good strategy or not if we go
bring guys like Bower that are bringing
this attention What markets are we not
in that we can bring in spend $ four or5
million on consulting firms and maybe
they're already doing this spend $4 or
$5 million on consulting firms and bring
the CMOS from these big firms to to to
do Partnerships with and tell them hey
if you do this we'll do this for you you
can broker a deal for them and then they
could come back and say if you did get
into this audience your viewership could
go from Rob can you pull up the NFL
viewership against all the other teams
that I ask you to pull up so here's the
numbers that's NFL to the left killing
everybody at
947 you know number of viewers per year
is what we're talking about and then you
got MLB and by the way NFL plays 17
games MLB plays I think 162 NBA is 82
and then NHL I think is also 82 I don't
know exactly how many games NHL plays
but 16 games is getting that what can we
do with MLB to take that 329 to 500 what
can we take you to take you to 600 so
watch this now watch this now somebody
who's watching this who's a player let's
just say some players are watching this
what happens if MLB is at 500 million
you know what that means if it's at 500
million contract that means contracts go
up 25% it's a revenue share percentage
on total revenue revenue up we all win
30% contract goes up that means if
you're making 40 a year now you mean I'm
going to get paid 55 a you saw what
Otani got paid the 2 million over 10
years and then 68 million the other but
it's really a 10 over seven 700 over 10
right 70 million a year type of contract
he got beautiful what if we can take
that to 100 million a year what if we
get the first billion dollar contract so
players ought to be excited about others
that can bring different unique eyeballs
to do it and I totally get you got to do
it in a way where you don't use your ex
in audience like we can't just go bring
you know half naked girls and hey here's
what we're going to do but the family
people left oh [__] that didn't work out
because the hot dogs you want to have
with your son yeah that was a terrible
idea I also understand that that Optics
uh but I think there's strategy on
getting a guy like you that entic a guy
like me to be like what's he going to
say today what's he going to do today
I'm curious yeah people were following
yeah for sure I think the landscape of
baseball is a little bit difficult
because you travel so much you play
every single day so the time when it's
better best to produce content is when
you're the busiest in the offseason
people don't do don't care as much about
content unless you start backlogging to
release in the middle of the season so
what you have to do is you have to find
a way to make those story lines easy for
players you have to find a way to make
the distribution of that the filming the
creation of it easy for players but you
have to find a way to make it
entertaining at the same time and that's
the bridge that they're trying to trying
to to cross right now um a lot of
players in season don't want to do the
extra interview they don't want to do an
hour you know shoot in the morning
because they're sleeping in trying to
recover trying to get ready for the game
NBA you have a lot more time in between
games to be able to do that you have a
practice two or three days in a row than
a game you have an afternoon to be able
to do some stuff NFL you have some time
to be able to do stuff you've seen I
think the Chiefs this year there's been
a lot of off field a lot of stuff
there's more time baseball's tough
because pitch could do it because you're
doing but not the hitters that's a good
point I can see that but still you know
there's ways to do it there's ways to do
it and and if I was able to like even
look at what um Pat mckae does right he
brings the existing players in and Aaron
Rogers comes in just gu going to come
back and play this season and what's
going to happen like oh my God what's G
is Aaron gonna come back for the Jets
it's going to be the fastest recovery
all time there's an element of that
that's bringing in you know a certain
set of uh eyeballs because what you also
don't want to do I also don't want to
change you yeah
I don't know if that makes sense like I
don't want McAfee to change yeah you
know who who's the other uh kicker in in
in uh football that's got the sick
physique Weatherford uh who is a um uh
uh he looks like he's a bodybuilder um
yeah I've I've had conversations with
him he's talking about Greg zerline no
I'm talking about Weatherford no I'm
talking to Steve Weatherford I said his
last name correctly that Weatherford
right there Steve Weatherford okay the
guy was a chisel if you go to his
Instagram account right now you won't
even believe what the guy looks like it
doesn't make any sense what he looks
like yeah go to his Instagram account
this this is a human specimen who this
guy is and by the way when you see him
face to face okay go on yeah he's
talking about how Weatherford tackled
him right there that that that's a
that's a human specimen this guy was a
kicker okay now he's a content creator
you you can stop it right there the
guy's got a stretching routine that he
teaches that's phenomenal I don't want
to change you by the way I don't care if
you're a
republican cuz if I if if I knew how to
use you that you're a Republican and
then there is something else coming up
and this other guy's a Obama or this
there's there's a way that's a story
line are you kidding me what K's brought
to MMA like he's really leaned into that
and there's tons of eyeballs now he goes
in there and fights someone and there's
resolution to that right but it's just
the story line of it you connect with a
completely you connect with like a full
half of your demographic where other
guys might connect with with the full
half of the other you know the other
half of theic course so now all of a
sudden they like hey Donald Trump shows
up to a game what do you mean Donald
Trump showed up yeah he showed up to a
game and then okay so now the other side
then Joe Biden shows up to a game and
well Barack Obama now shows up to a game
and then now Bush shows up to a game now
it's like oh wow who's going to show up
to the next game I think there's an
element of that where you can bring an
audience that there's a lot of
conservative families that love baseball
I would say the biggest conservative fan
base of any sport is probably baseball
more than NFL and more than than you
know uh uh NBA so how do you tap into
that and tap into it in a way where you
know you're not offending and you're
allowing and and then the commission has
to come out and say look I I don't mean
to say anything that's going to offend
anybody Republicans love baseball
Democrats love baseball Trump fans love
baseball Obama fans love baseball we
have Cubans who come from a communist
Nation communist loves baseball
socialists love baseball baseball
doesn't care about your politics B
baseball is the most unique game in the
world because it's fun it's spiritual
it's this but we welcome whites blacks
we're the most diverse sport out of all
of them I would be selling that yeah I
would be selling the fact that I by the
way I think baseball is the most diverse
abut nationality league but do you know
who talks about that I've never heard
about that I I don't hear that being
sold there's at any given time in a
clubhous you might be sitting next to
people from six to 10 different
countries sick I love it yeah Australia
Germany Japan Korea uh Venezuela Puerto
Rico Dominican I just Brazil you just
keep going down the list there's I mean
Kenley was from Kura most people could
spell it or point where it was on a map
exactly yeah I mean but that you'll have
all those players sitting next to each
other in a clubhouse getting along
fighting for a World Series a common
goal coming together bridging all the
different cultures and the communication
gaps and everything finding ways to
communicate I was with Jose Ramirez in
Cleveland and he's one of my favorite
teammates I've ever had we couldn't
speak very well he learned more English
as time went along but we we couldn't
communicate very well but we found ways
of like you know body language and stuff
like that and we'd actually like talk to
each other in that way all the time he's
one of my favorite guys um you have
those moments I think that's an
important thing to show but people don't
get to see those things because there's
no there's no documentation of it you
know the show Hard Knocks um imagine the
New York Yankees have a Hard Knock type
show that goes All Season like what is
what does that
bring what kind of fan engagement does
that bring to that organization now you
you produce it in house you don't show
the technical stuff you know the The
Scouting the exact numbers but you show
the players what are they coming to the
stadium wearing what are they doing off
the field what are those interactions in
the clubhouse film it have your PR
people have your your media people
screen everything and then cut the
players in on the performance of it find
a distribution Network a Netflix uh put
it on YouTube whatever the the
distribution strategy is cut the players
in on it the more that they're involved
um the better the show does the more
money they get paid and running it at
even or a loss as a marketing thing
you're going to go spend a bunch of
marketing on Yankees res whatever the
team is every year anyway what what kind
of fan engagement you've been doing the
YouTube game for long enough you can see
the type the number of views that you
generate you can see the number of views
that guys like Mr Beast are generating
and the the Enterprise Value that that
creates Mr Beast advertisement is more
lucrative more valuable than a Super
Bowl ad and he's putting a video up
every single week like what or every two
weeks or whatever it is like what what
is the value that could be had there by
delivering that type of content
something that's so unique that no one
else is doing to an audience like I I
don't know what the numbers would be but
the the impact on the game would be
astronomical if you could see what Aaron
judge was doing week in week out
preparing for this upcoming game if you
could see the unfiltered conversations
clean whatever you want to however you
want to structure your brand that's fine
but some of the unfiltered conversations
in the clubhouse I had a conversation
with mie Betts when I was in uh LA and I
love mookie one of my favorite guys um
great player great teammate love him we
got an argument one day over who would
win if the pitchers had to hit and play
defense and the position players had to
pitch like who who would win and we went
on we had everyone in the clubhouse we
had the manager we had everyone that was
walking in and I had just set my Vlog
camera up there and it was a one angle
it was you couldn't see half the people
on the screen but it was one of the most
engaging moments of my Vlog because
people are like oh this is what goes on
in a clubhouse these are the types of
conversations that people have in the
clubhouse can you imagine being able to
see that week in week out day in day out
what kind of fan engagement and value
that would bring that' be incredible
where is that by the way it shows up
amazingly when you have 13 inning games
and you run through um right before you
came to the Dodgers Russell Martin
pitched a complete half inning yeah and
he's the catcher Pat we were out of
everything we're like in the 14th inning
there's nobody left there's there's like
two starters left we're not going to use
them why we can't get them stretched out
because we need them tomorrow on the
next day and so Russell Martin comes in
and pitches a half inning yeah it's
crazy like what did Russell Martin think
going into that moment
what how did he prepare for it it was on
Sports Center and it was ahead of web
gems yeah everybody was like Russell
Martin if you don't know 55 55 is coming
into pitch that doesn't happen in La
yeah the only time he comes to the mound
is when he walks to it yeah on the plate
yeah well there's a storyline there
right like where's the followup to it
like I want to know what he was thinking
hey when you like break down this at bat
you catch you call pitches like why did
you throw this like like there's there's
a lot of things that you can play off
that with that would make it very easy
for him to produce content if the next
day he comes in the team's like hey 15
minutes I need just walk me through this
cut up some social Clips put it out
there I where is that it and Adrian
Gonzalez pointing at him and going you
you can see him he was stay you when he
walked up to the plate I would be so
interested in that listen look what it
did for F1 drive to survive so so drive
to survive blue F1 up how much how many
millions of dollars has that single Show
created for f one in the American market
and it doesn't cover the races it covers
the conflict and the personality they
hardly show the
races and then you build Superstars
people didn't know and people in the
states didn't know who Daniel Ricardo
was now they love him people didn't know
Gunther Steiner now they love him like
Gunther Steiner was like one of hass's
biggest stars bringing in sponsorships
millions of dollars of sponsorships
because he was a driver drive to survive
star like what kind of value does that
create for an organization you build one
Superstar like look at Otani like the
Dodgers just paid $700 million to
acquire Otani that was not a oh he's
just worth this we'll pay it and we'll
take a loss that's a calculated decision
they assessed that number and said over
the lifetime of this contract in the
Asian market in US market in Jersey
sales in media and stuff like that we're
going to make more than this $700
million we're going to have our margins
we're going to be able that's a business
decision so if one player now auton is a
a freak he's a superstar probably the
most talented guy ever to play the game
in the history of it like if one guy can
bring in over $700
million what is the value of building a
superstar look at what Conor McGregor
did look at what Michael Jordan did look
at go Tom Brady like what is the value
of Tom Brady to the NFL over 20 years
what is the Superstar creating machine
what's the engine that's going on in MLB
UFC is like the gold standard of this
they create new Superstars all the time
like if you go back UFC 5 years ago you
have like Jon Jones and you have Conor
McGregor you have uh the Diaz brothers
you have a couple select Superstars
Ronda Rhonda you have the UFC today is
bigger than it has ever been and those
people aren't fighting how like they've
created new Superstars they have a
machine they have UFC embedded they have
Contender series they have Ultimate
Fighter they have this engine to build
Superstars and to build valuable assets
with their athletes can you do me a
favor Rob uh uh I wrote one word down
and he said it earlier go on YouTube
let's let's just check this out go on
YouTube and type in NFL okay and zoom in
a little bit so we can see it as well
how many subscribers does NFL's YouTube
channel have let's write this down 12
and a half okay uh so NFL is at 12 and a
half go to
MLB 5 point something I think what is it
MLB is
okay 4.88 okay go to
NBA NBA is what 21.3 dominating
everybody okay go to
NHL 2 million okay go to uh
UFC 17 and a half go to
WWE 99
million so if if I'm and by the way
which sport is the fakest out of all the
sports right I mean we all know I mean I
hopefully we know at this point you know
WWE is a lot of storyline you know
reality television sports but guess what
you mean there is a there is genius in
the entertainment marketing aspect of it
creating controversy WWE was all about
creating the next fight the next match
the next villain the next enemy who's
the villain in major league baseball
right now who's the villain I was I was
the biggest villain I think when I was
playing but by the way can you Ty in
greatest villain of Major League
Baseball who were the villains on
baseball uh well it depends on who who
you're a fan of if you're a Yankees fan
prior it was a Red Sox player dude I
think just put like the villain biggest
villains baseball who Bryce Harper okay
guess what I freaking love watching
Bryce Harper who else you got there as a
villain lucky fing Dent became a
multi-generational statement the Boston
Red Sox would and they would say the
whole thing up Bucky effing Dent he was
such the villain cuz he hit the home run
on that it was a one game playoff last
game of the season and so he became this
multigenerational symbol of defeat okay
he was their villain let's see Roger
Clemens totally get it he's a villain uh
A-Rod yes people love to hate him okay
but guess what the guy hit 6 96 home
runs 98 home runs I think he was for
short of 700 he always wanted to come
back and do it bonds absolute villain
rocker you clearly remember him being a
villain in the old Braves lineup
different Reon different reasons yeah
Sheffield villain I was going to say
Joey Bel Albert Bell villain can you go
uh is it show Mo or that's it they got
Chase Utley there yeah you know to me I
think maybe I that's why I would never
be a commissioner Major League Baseball
because if I was a commissioner major
baseball I would be front and center
saying look I'm a little bit concerned
because obviously the tensions are very
high with the next game that's coming up
uh and this is a competitive sport these
people have spent 30 years of their life
working you don't know what's going to
happen it's exactly and everybody has to
tune in and then you you even create
like the you know but you know we are
fully prepared for it on what's going to
happen and um we've talked to both teams
we're ready for all of it you know both
teams want this championship this is
going to be a dog fight it's probably
going to be one that's going to be one
of our most viewed like I'm like oh my
God what's going to happen and you know
we understand we we have talked to you
know um Trevor Bower about some of his
Antics and he he is willing to listen to
some of us but again Trevor is Trevor we
don't know what's going to happen when
he goes to the mound and on the other
side they've been told if Trevor pitches
you know so we want to bring the
tensions down we've talked to all the
umps but uh we're excited about this you
know the entire Major League Baseball is
excited about this that's what it is you
it's got to be a little bit of that and
by the way do kids watch UFC of course
they do I don't even know who I'm facing
in that scenario and I'm excited for the
game yeah that's what I want I want to
be like okay what the hell is this guy
talking about and I know in most sports
commissioner job is not like Dana
White's job Dana's a different kind of a
commissioner Dana's a boss right so you
can't necessarily most Major League
Baseball commissioners are unknown yep
the first time you ever heard of n
Manfred is when when what happened with
Houston Astros you're like wait what's
the commissioner's name Manfred is not
going to do anything they're going to
keep there and they're going to go
through this are you kidding me who boom
and then now you know in basketball you
always know David Stern because David
Stern was kind of like Dana White yeah
those if you look at if you look at when
NBA really took off that's when it was
that started the the trajectory if you
look at Dana White that's what UFC is
the fastest growing sport it's it's
blowing up worldwide too yeah like you
have
every ethnicity likes it yeah yeah you
have to have tension storyline you have
to lean into that and then you have to
deliver that content to people where
they are now let me let me ask this any
major superstars from MLB have they
reached out to you you don't need to
give names but are you in conversation
with major Superstars current and PR uh
pre uh retired I've had a lot of
conversation players coaches staff GMS
like through this whole time like
privately behind the scenes um it's been
a very you know it's been a very
supportive thing it's really helped me a
lot to know that like people in the game
that I've interacted with that I've been
in the clubhouse with that I've played
for that I've been around
like don't view me the way that the the
public views me so and and so then the
next thing is cu I you told me about the
Tom glavin situation where Tom was like
I don't know if i' want I'd want to play
today with all the pressures of what's
going on you know the comments you he
was very clear about that yeah yeah so
are there who who are the most vocal
Superstars that have defended you
publicly mooki probably mooki yeah okay
um because when I when I think about the
sport the sport is filled with a lot of
superstars that were uh uh redeemed
themselves right and they were forgiven
okay it's filled with it all over the
place A-Rod is now maybe one of the best
I actually like to hear a-rod's analysis
I think he's a very a teacher that
transformation in as short of a time
span went from being hated by basically
everyone in baseball and like 3 four
years later was calling like playoff
games and pretty much universally
enjoyed trusted color man people are
trusting the opinion and in social media
well A-Rod says this and he used to play
so I buy that I like wow where's the
where's where's The Angst yeah he sued
the league and then is now representing
the league in like quick order and the
transformation has been incredible he
knows his stuff though like he's a
like the amount of knowledge has there's
a lot of value there I watch A-Rod give
analysis and I'm like you know here's
what I used to do I used to put my glove
in the freezer and I used to do this and
this is that for this many years this is
what I always did why why and let me
tell you why I would do it
because it's kind of weird and then I
would put it down and I would have this
be on top of it and then when sometimes
you got to choke the bad when it this
this that when I'm facing this person
this is the angle this's what I do my
foot when him in by the way it's always
great when it's the the couple Clips
with him and Pete Rose and think about
the two guys that are talking about the
you know both of them have a lot of
controversy I think both of them belong
in the Hall of Fame if you ask me but
again I'm not Cooperstown so it's not my
decision to make but look at them two
right look at Michael Jordan took a
break came back okay David Stern
understood because Stern you know took
care of that guy and he came back and
you know he brought a whole different
lens to the league look at uh bonds look
at Maguire and Sosa what those guys did
to the leue League look at J Jones Dana
White knowing the the background J Jones
has are you kidding me Lawrence Taylor
okay and think about NFL without an LT
right Kobe Bryant there's so many of
these guys that we can talk about
because and you know deshun Watson you
know even he went through some things
that he went through Ray Lewis I don't
need to get into Ray Lewis Antics and
and what stories if you followed the
game you know what accusations were made
of Ray Lewis and then he changed himself
and he's got a different life Mike Tyson
is on that list right we've had Mike on
multiple times Dennis Rodman you know
imagine the league without a Dennis
Rodman he was like one of the oh you you
never knew what he was going to do it's
like you got a open layup he starts
Waits waits for you to come score
because he was refusing to score any
points that game he just wanted to get
28 rebounds and zero points because he
wanted to say I can get 28 rebounds and
zero points while he's got a yellow hair
and in the interview he's wearing some
weird things but guess what you follow
at the game what was going on the
biggest factor is the the the game is
about Redemption forgiveness and
realizing everybody sins in a different
way if if if the if the superstars like
the reason why I asked the question
about superstars I was in a former
company and you know couple of the guys
screwed up and royally they screwed up
stupid screw up right worse than yours
you cuz yours is not what you did wasn't
illegal it's a choice that you and the
girl made in this St but this was
actually a screw up but they were good
guys they just did something very stupid
they deserve to get punished but not
deserve to get thrown out and losing
their license for the rest of their
lives so I went and I sat down and I
said I talked to the individual first we
had a one-on-one conversation and I said
you know what you did is stupid yes you
know what you did is selfish you know
you could have hurt other people yeah I
know to do you fully get I totally get
done okay I think you're a good guy I
think what you did is dumb uh and what
are you willing to do improve and change
in this area P okay all right and I feel
like you're being real I went and I
spoke on their behalf behind closed
doors to the league that I was a part of
insurance is a very regulated industry
financial industry is very regulated and
these guys got Second Chances what
happened
afterwards they redeemed themselves now
obviously you have guard rails to make
sure they can do like maybe you're
double-checking their policies that said
submitting that you don't do like the
other people and you're double-checking
by calling clients and all this stuff
but guess what they ended up becoming
great SU successful citizens did very
well company grew they grew everything
good happened I think you know the
biggest onus here I would put on
superstars who have been through what
you've been through for some of these
Superstars to come out and say look guys
at least what I did was wrong and I
broke the law this guy didn't break the
law he just did something stupid you
mean to tell me you were in a superstar
where isn't there a reporter right now
on Monday Night Football that there's
videos of him saying what kind of girls
he like back in the days Collinsworth
whatever his name is there's videos
circulating of this guy back in the days
when he was oh yeah Chris Collins chis I
believe it's Chris con he was at
University of Florida he came out he was
at the Cincinnati B that's the interview
all the way at the top you just pulled
it up right there yeah yeah see look how
young he is yeah and I like girls that
aren't too bright because you can trick
them a little bit okay he says that in
an interview you know what he is right
now he's a grown man right now probably
embarrassed by saying some stupid like
this that we've all said some of us
weren't famous we didn't say it on
camera we said it off camera but the
Market's forgiven him and he's one of
the best guys on doing Monday Night
Football I think he does Monday night or
he does NFL he does one of the two
because Monday night is Troy Aman and
the other guy uh uh uh again I don't
know which night he does but he's very
very good at what he does Chris Collins
board right ex player smart knows the
game yeah said some crazy things when he
was a kid 7980 coming out of we can't
assume who doesn't who doesn't so all
I'm saying saying is these guys need to
make the phone calls that's what I'm
saying they got to make the phone calls
they got to reach out some of them have
okay some of them have they reached out
to them not to you to to the league okay
got it and and if that's the case
then then at that point you know some of
the teams and leagues have to make a
decision is this like the first year
where it's like hey guys I'm here I'm
available if you're interested or have
they had a chance to sign you for a few
months and nothing's happened yet yeah
um I mean once the Dodgers released me
in early 2023 there was like a month but
where I was a free agent could sign with
anyone before I signed in Japan um but
that was coming right off of the you
know theion and everything I still had
outstanding lawsuit whatever um now all
that stuff's cleared so yeah this has
been the first like kind of free agency
after all the all the stuff right now
yeah okay so so it's fresh so something
could
happen and uh is there a set profile of
a certain teams that would be willing to
take more of a risk on a guy like you
than
others I'm not sure um I would like to
think that well I I know on the field I
can help any team um I think it makes a
lot of sense for teams that are looking
for starting pitching that are
contending uh you can sign me for you
know basically you have to pay league
minimum to someone to fill the roster
spot anyway league minimum plus
incentives you can get someone that
could perform at a sa young level for
you know to to bolster your team um I
think that makes a lot of sense uh but
again like I I'm not I'm not in the
position of a of an owner of a team I've
never been in those positions so I don't
know all the things that have to be
considered um but yeah I think a a team
like that like a team like the
Diamondbacks let's say I'm just pulling
a team out but you know went to the
World Series last year have a good young
team someone like the Orioles maybe good
young team need a a starting pitcher
need a veteran need someone that's like
been in the playoffs a lot those types
of things I think those
are those are teams that would make
sense to me um but again I you know I'm
just looking I I don't care I'll I'll
play for whatever team I just want a
opportunity to go play and do what I
love to do and prove that I've been able
to learn from you know past mistakes I
think that's an important message to
deliver to the youth too like everyone's
going to mess up some more publicly than
others but if you learn from your
mistakes if you take accountability for
where you went wrong and you can be
better can be that Redemption you know
what you just remind me of you just
remind me of something you know when um
some of the players or owners say things
like I have I saw an interview you did
with a couple guys three weeks ago I
don't know who the two guys were but
they did a very good job interviewing
you they look like they were Twins were
they brothers were they related or no
they're just that W WFAN I don't know
which one it was but they did a very
good job interviewing you and you know
the question was where the guy says I
have a daughter so does he you know is
that the same group you're yeah I have a
daughter so does he so what do we do you
know what do we explain to our daughters
and what do we explain to this and Tom's
got daughters two of them I got two
daughters and I got two boys so how dare
you talk to somebody like that what kind
of an example is he for a man and da d d
d da okay so I don't know if you know to
the people who are the owners who ask
the question about daughters let's
overcome that objection
together
yesterday we're we're having lunch with
Will gadera author of unreasonable
Hospitality who you have to read this
book but we're having this conversation
Will's a freaking fantastic guy he ran
11 Madison number one restaurant in the
world stud great operator sold it he no
longer owns it and he no longer makes
any decisions with the restaurant the
menu changes I want to make sure I
explained that he hasn't done that for
since he sold it which was a few years
ago so the new menu is not his new menu
it's the new person's menu I asked a
question what movie have you ever
watched back to back okay and they're
like what do you mean have you ever
watched the same movie back to back what
do you mean you watch it for two hours
it finish it you watch it again okay uh
no I've never done that okay Eric says
he watched John Wick back toback but
it's just kind of playing in the
background while he's working right I
said the only movie I've watched back
toback is Judge with you ever seen the
judge with Robert Downey Jr and Robert
Deval no dude highly recommend you go
watch it by yourself nobody run just sit
there and watch even on the flight back
watch the movie I guarantee you're going
to get emotional I guarantee you you're
going to get
emotional because the premise of the
movie
is that Robert Deval is the father of
Robert Downey Jr they're living in a
small town the father is the judge okay
and you know a kid in school his son
does something real stupid his son and
he puts him in jail I think something
like that where he wasn't forgiv him him
he was very very tough on his son Robert
dowy Jr who got into a car accident with
his brother that was supposed to go be a
major league baseball player pitcher
gets injured and he finishes his
brother's career he was that good of a
pitcher right you know he was going to
make it to the next level it's just the
best fight scenes with a father and a
son and then the judge Deval with
another kid who did did some
stupid he decides to be lenient with the
second guy cuz he think he feels guilty
that he put his son in jail and to the
second guy what does he do he doesn't
put him he releases him and gives him a
little bit more freedom that guy ends up
going in killing a couple people and
actually committing a crime okay and
then eventually later on the judge does
something gets accused of driving and
killing that guy that got out of jail
okay whether it's true or not you have
to watch the movie to see what happens
at the end and guess who ends up
representing the Father the Son Robert
dowy Jor yeah and they have this best
scene the best fight SC like why could
you just love me do you know I finished
number one in my class [__] you Dad but
like that like it's awesome
right to the people who say I have a
daughter and how do I explain this to
them watch this movie because we've all
been in one of the situations where
we've made a stupid decision or someone
in our family's made a stupid decision
and we wish somebody would have Grace
with them whether it's our kid whether
it's us whether it's our parents whether
it's our siblings and we know these
people are good people and sometime we
just deserve Grace
right so this whole concept about well
how do I explain it to my daughter
you're assuming your daughter's going to
walk on water for the rest of her life
you're assuming you walk on water you're
assuming your kids walk on water none of
us do at some point what our kids are
going to want to see is the level of
Grace We're going to have and Grace
doesn't just apply to kids that we have
Grace applies to people we work with as
well there's a lot of people that need a
second chance in their lives and I just
feel a guy like you who potentially
could end up losing $350 million plus if
you never play ever again I think the
league would miss out on having a guy
like you play I think the fans would
lose I think you would lose the
opportunity of being a great testimony
in the future for other kids that are
acting stupid for you to go and give
them counsel and give them feedback cuz
someone has to have a big fall like
yours to be able to have a better
testimony because now you have a moral
authority to influence younger guys that
even they don't have y because they've
not gone through what you've gone
through yours was more public so you
could come out and be like listen guys
here's all I'll tell you watch out for
this don't do this you're going to want
to do this don't fall for this they're
going to say this don't fall for d d
focus on this da D and it's like okay
[__] who else is going to be better than
this guy this guy lost $100 million over
three years he came back and played yeah
he finished his career won a World
Series won a sa young again and redeemed
himself and won of greatest stories of
all time in the history of sports
awesome but he's right I'm going to
listen to
him that that's the part for me
where you know even who was the coach in
in NFL that he would always give people
Second Chances and they won three Super
Bowls and one of them was with Switzer
but it was really his team who was that
Jimmy Johnson where did Jimmy Johnson
get into Hall of Fame you ever seen
Jimmy Johnson get into the Hall of Fame
and he's being surprised how he reacts I
don't know if you saw that video or not
have you seen when Jimmy Johnson they
come up to him they said you going into
the Hall of Fame I don't know if we can
play it because the the YouTube's not
going to let us play cuz somebody else
owns it so don't don't show it in the
screen but they come up to Jimmy Johnson
and he has no clu it's in the middle of
a show and they say Jimmy I'm here to
tell you you're inducted you could put
surprise you're conducted to the Hall of
Fame you should see how he
cries you should see how he cries you
should see how he's loved I think I've
seen that video dude awesome right this
is it it's right here don't play it in
the back but this is it this is the clip
and they're tell look at he's shaking
right he's shaking just focus on his
body look at him he doesn't even what is
he thinking about right there all those
years Jerry Jones firing him you know
you didn't do it you did this you look
look at this it's pure celebrating it's
pure joy this man who's in his 60s is is
officially 14 years old for this 90
seconds we all relate to this he made
mistakes he gave players in the NFL
second chances he gave NFL players that
screwed up second chances they love him
like a father look at Troy Aman they
love this man like a father like a
father I think dmlb has a chance to do
that with you and I hope they do I hope
they give you a second chance I can't
wait to be at that game uh if they give
it to you I can't wait to uh uh uh you
know talk to you about it that night
when it happens I'm like how you feeling
man what's the word what are you
thinking about it I think uh it'll be a
a a a great example
of a league that can show Redemption and
a second chance to other kids who have
screwed up who are about to go pick up
drugs and cocaine and Al alcohol because
they've given up on life I think the MLB
can Inspire that 14-year-old kid that
16y old kid to say continue going on
Larry Bird his father shot himself
because he owed so much money to the
community he was a gambler and he was an
alcoholic and his three brothers and
Larry gave up on life and a guy gave him
another chance to said come back and do
something he became one of the greatest
players of all time it's an awesome
story how many people relate to guy like
that that could be a drug addict drug
dealer ruin his life because of his
father committing suicide what a great
story Larry Bird is to those people I
think MLB has that chance and I hope you
know if they hear this message I hope um
they give you that shot because I think
it'll make for a great story so yeah I
think so too I hope so any final
thoughts Tom before we wrap up yeah I
think America needs to understand
exactly what you just said I'm only the
man I am and the dad I am because I've
taken the mistakes I made in life and
I've turned that into a body of
knowledge called experience and I can
bring that and bring that to my daughter
with authenticity and I think
authenticity is what America needs I
think it would turn down some of the uh
tension that we have overall but I think
that is something that I think all
sports fan remember and baseball is a
symbol of redemption I can strike out
three times but they still want me in
then bottom of the ninth inning because
I'm still capable and I think the sport
of baseball just by its nature is
redemption and I think we need to
remember um none of us are perfect and
we're the people we are because of what
we do with our mistakes and it's a
symbol of the fabric of America and I
think you summed it up perfectly yeah I
think baseball can use Trevor Bower to
make baseball better that's a that's a
goal of mine um I've always wanted to
make the game better leave it in a
better spot than I found it I think I've
accomplished a small part of that on the
training side but I have you know
another talk about decade runs you know
I have another decade run in me to to
help in a lot of other ways um I'd love
the opportunity to to be able to do that
can't wait for that day I remember when
we got the call when I was in Bermuda
and the you know lawyer said Pat you're
officially minority on the Yankees it
was a dream I couldn't believe what
happened and my son was watch the only
documentary Dylan ever cried in was the
documentary of Yogi Bara you ever
watched it I I I had to go watch it
again I had to go watch it immediately
I'm like what happened to this
documentary like what a freaking story
you know even Yogi's story where they
eventually had to make up him and
steinner not coming back to the game and
but yeah so if if a guy like me can go
from where I was at and you know some of
you don't know my background who I was
what I did to where I'm at right now
that's why I love baseball baseball's a
spiritual game it's a very unique game
very very unique game and I think
baseball's got a big chance here to do
something big anyways Trevor uh it's
great to finally uh have this
conversation with you this was a blast
uh I'm looking forward to see what
happens there I hope the right people
see this content and they make the
decision for themselves but uh future
looks bright regardless of what happens
uh whether it's this or something else
I'd love to see this be the part but I
think you're going to do fine for the
rest of your life um but I'd love
selfishly I'd love to see you have a
Redemption story and play of Major
Leagues yeah so if you of course if you
also feel this way and you got guys in
Major League Baseball or people that are
influencers share this with them go to a
certain minute and say watch it from
here to here or watch it from here to
there and if you like to see make in
major leagues and you're like I don't
know anybody in baseball just share with
everybody have them watch his story
because it's a story of redemption a
person that was accused for something he
didn't do and cost him the Love of the
Game that he couldn't play at the
highest level that he wanted to play and
I don't think that's fair so I think he
deserves a second chance God bless
everybody take care bye-bye
bye-bye